hi I'm sahil Sharif and I'm going to be
talking about lifting the party this
entries
this is Joint work with arcadev nikhil
and swagato
and I'll be starting with a overview of
decision trees and priority decision
entries given giving an example of how
they're relevant to proof complexity and
why we care about priority disintegrity
lower bonds
then we'll move on to our theorem which
is a lifting theorem from decision trees
to parity to cngs
and we'll pretty much see the whole
proof of it and then we'll go to what
our notion of a stifled function is
most of us have come across the same
trees before in computer science it's a
very natural model of computation it's
very simple and also very useful
you have an input which in our case here
is an N bit string
and we're going to run down this tree
from the root to a leaf in the following
manner
we start at the root we query whatever
bit is specified at that node and
depending on what the value of the bit
is zero or one we take that
corresponding Edge out of that node and
we continue this until we reach a leaf
when we reach a leaf we output the label
at that leaf and we say that a decision
tree computes a relation if for every
single input the output of the decision
Tree on that input
is a valid output
parity this entries are very similar but
they're not studies as much and they're
not as well understood
the only difference is that instead of
having bits to query at each node we
have a subset of bits and when we query
the parity of a subset of bits we get a
single bit 0 or 1 telling us whether
there was an even number of ones or an
odd number of ones in that subset of
pins
and we do the same thing we reach a leaf
and we output the label at that leaf
now we'll jump into proof complexity and
why these are relevant to proof
complexity
and to do this we look at the following
task
so we're given an unset CNF that's an
unsatisfiable set of clauses
and given such an unset CNF we have a
task defined which takes as input and
assignment to the variables of the CNF
and it outputs what we're supposed to
output on that input is any of the
Clauses that are falsified by that
assignment and such a clause is
guaranteed to exist because the the CNF
is not satisfiable
no decision a decision tree or a parity
decision tree that actually solves this
task is actually a proof that our CNF
was unsatisfiable
even though the correctness of this
decision tree relies on it being correct
on all two to the N inputs we can
actually verify that the decision to
your priority this entry is correct in
just the size of the tree
so if we have a small size decision
share priority decision tree that is a
short proof that the CNF is
unsatisfiable
now given that we believe that unsat is
not an NP or
assuming that we believe that unsat is
not an NP we should also believe and it
would also imply that there are
unsatisfiable cnfs for which we do not
have any small decision tree or priority
decision tree that solves this task and
indeed that is true it's well known that
there are unsatisfiable cnfs that
require exponentially large decision
trees and also parity decision trees
although that was proven much more
recently
so the next step for us is to look at
decision Dax instead of decision trees
so these are ways in which you can
compress a decision tree to get rid of
redundancy and it can in some cases lead
to a huge saving in size
so for decision dags again we know that
there are some cnfs that require
exponentially large decision Dags
but
a huge open problem one of the frontiers
of proof complexity right now is that we
don't know of any unsatisfiable CNF
that's known to require super
polynomically large parity this index so
for all we know NP could be equal to
coin P just because of parity decision
index
and this is our motivation for studying
such uh priority query models
now in this talk we're not actually
going to look at priority to see index
we're going to stick to parity decision
trees
and what we're going to do is we're
going to show a different way of proving
lower bounds on parity decent entries
so the previous proofs here by itself
are very specific to the problems that
they were looking at and we're going to
show a more General way of showing
priority to entry lower bonds and
hopefully that can generalize in time to
parity this index
so what's the problem with lower bonds
how do we improve lower Bonds on such
tree models
these can be characterized by What's
called the adversary method
so what an adversary does is the
adversary answers the queries made by
the decision entry in order to delay
the decision entry from being able to
give an output
and this characterizes this energy
complexity in the sense that this
decision tree complexity of a search
problem is C if and only if an adversary
can force the queryer to make C queries
foreign
about just by looking at which bits are
queried and which bits are unqueried
then we can think about what we should
answer to a new query in order to make
the least amount of progress for the
queryer but in the case of parity
decision trees we're not fixing bits
there are no query and unquered bits
instead there are priorities that are
queried and this can be very hard to
reason about
and I believe it's the main reason why
we don't have as many party decentral or
ones
so we did what people generally do in
such a situation what we proved is a
lifting theorem that for any relation s
the parity decision tree size of s
composed with the three bit majority
function is at least the decision tree
size of s
and it follows from this that we can
find unset cnfs which require large
parity decision tree size and all that
we need to do in order to find such cnfs
is to just prove a decision tree size
lower bound which is much easier
we should note that this holds from any
other gadgets not just for the majority
guys around three bits the whole Square
indexing as well and uh Paul beam and
sajan Korat independently proved a
similar theorem and which is also being
presented at atcs their theorem focused
just on the indexing Gadget but that's
because their paper was more generally
about properties of composition with the
indexing Gadget
right so what is this composition with
majority why is composition helpful in
lifting theorems for that let's just see
what a composite relation is
so say you have a relation that takes in
as input a five bit five bits
this this relation composed with the
three-bit majority would take in as
input 15 bits which is divided into five
blocks of three bits each so each of
these blocks I'm going to call a gadget
and given these 15 bits by applying the
majority function on each block
we get an implicit five bit uh input to
the original relation
and any valid output on our implicit X
is a valid output for our composed
relation
and the reason composed relations are so
useful is that these gadgets kind of act
as Shields that Shield you from the
implicit input so although we're making
parity queries to the Y variables
in some sense that's restricting the
kind of the ways in which we can affect
the implicit X
and what we will prove is that it it's
going to be equivalent to just querying
X instead of making parity queries
tracks
and this is how a general standard
lifting theorem lower bonds go
what they eventually come up with is an
adversary that answers the more
complicated queries which in our case
are priority queries
and internally this adversary is going
to use a decision tree adversary for the
original relation
and this allows us to show that the
number of queries needed for the parity
to entry
is going to be at least the number of
queries needed for the decision Tree on
the original relation
and with a slight modification of this
outline we could even show this property
this entry size
uh we should note here that lots of
lifting theorems have been proven in the
past but none of them imply this
specific statement there are some that
do show lower bounds on priority
decision tree size but the lower bond
that they show are just 2 to the power
of randomized decision tree complexity
of s which is weaker than what we want
so what property do we use of priority
queries and how do we work against them
it's really quite simple so suppose we
have some priority constraints let's see
how the set of solutions changes
depending on what those constraints are
so initially when there are no parity
constraints all your bits are free which
I'm going to represent here as these
empty boxes which just can be filled
independently with whatever bits we want
now suppose someone adds a constraint
here X2 plus X3 plus X6 is equal to 1.
we're going to view this constraint as a
constraint on x2 it's just saying X2 is
equal to X3 plus X6 plus X plus one
and all the bits other than X2 are
completely free and we're going to
represent this by just putting a d where
X2 should be saying that it's dependent
on the others but the other bits are
entirely free
and as we get new constraints each new
independent constraint adds a new
dependent bit and all other bits are
continue to be free and to make this
formal this is just gaussian elimination
at play so just some bits that are
pivots
the rest of the bits can be set
completely free
and using this we're ready to actually
show an adversary against a PDT so what
we need to do is for every parity query
that comes our way we should tell
as an adversary we should be able to
give an answer that delays the priority
this entry from giving an output
so the priority queries are going to be
made to these 15 bits at the bottom
which are an input to our composed
relation
and the 15 bits at the bottom are going
to implicitly Define an X since we don't
know any of the bits at the bottom we
don't know what the implicit X is each
bit could be 0 or 1 independently
and say we get our first query here
which is just what is the priority of
these three bits
what we're going to do is we're going to
just answer this query arbitrarily and
we'll choose one of these bits to be a
dependent bit and the other is to be
free so in this case we choose the bit
in the second Gadget to be dependent and
all the other gadgets still are
completely free to choose their bits
now given that there's a dependency in
the second Gadget what we want to we
will have to deal with it is eventually
and that's what makes parity queries
annoying
but the fact that we've composed with
majority actually allows us to ignore
that dependent bit completely and to
ignore it we have to ensure that that
bit is irrelevant
so what we're going to do is we're going
to actually fix the second Gadget
completely we're going to choose a value
of our second bit so we're going to
query what is
the value of
the second bit of the implicit X so for
this we're using our internal adversary
against the relation s
and say our adversary tells us that the
second bit is equal to one then we're
going to fill in the rest of the bits in
the second Gadget to one
so now the second Gadget is always going
to Output one it doesn't matter what the
dependent bit is and all the other bits
are free this is
a very good State of Affairs
and we can continue this process
the priority decency entry makes more
queries there are more dependent bits
that are created and we've made more
queries to our internal adversary to
find out what those gadgets should
output
and at some point the parity this entry
reaches a leaf and it's going to Output
some value o
now notice that in this example here the
first and fourth gadgets are completely
untouched the priority industry entry
does not care about what inputs there
are over there it's already confident
that the output is o
so that means that it doesn't matter
what the values of the implicit X are in
the first and fourth bit we already know
that the that O is a valid output for
the implicit X
and if we can actually give an answer to
what is the value of s on the implicit X
that means that the
the decision tree adversary has already
forced us to make dtfs many queries
that implies that the number of
dependent bits over here is already DT
of s
and so this actually gives us a parity
dissidential saying that the parity
decision tree has made at least 80 of as
many queries so this is a lifting
theorem already it's not a size lifting
theorem
but it is a query lifting theorem
and we can adapt this to make it a size
lifting theorem with just one small
change
and that is earlier we said that the
adversary can just answer arbitrarily
whenever dependency giving query was
made
now we're going to change that and say
that the adversary answers in such a way
that
we go to the smaller subtree of the PTT
so now we're guaranteed that the number
of dependencies that come up is at most
log of the PDT size
but on the other hand we know that the
number of dependencies has to be at
least the decision tree complexity of s
putting both of these together we get
that the PDT size has to be at least 2
to the power this is entry complexity of
s
now what about other gadgets apart from
majority let's take majority on five
bits as an illustrative example
in such a case we can ignore two
dependencies in each Gadget even if two
bits are dependent we can completely
ignore them if we fix the other three
bits uh to be the same
so the number of dependencies that are
going to arise is going to be twice the
dissidential complexity of s
and so if we go through the same
calculation we see that the PDT size of
s compost with the 5-bit majority is at
least the decision tree size of s
squared
and what we're using here is the fact
that these gadgets allow us to just
ignore uh bits we are allowed to ignore
some number of bits while still being
able to set the gadget to zero or to one
as we wish
and this is what we're calling a k
stifled Gadget so a gadget G is case
typefold if for any subset of K bits
we can completely
stifle those K bits by just not looking
at them and setting the rest of the
values and fixing it to zero or fixing
it to one as we wish
so in such cases we have the lifting
theorem that the parity this entry size
of as composed with G is at least the
decision tree size of s to the power k
some examples of stifled functions are
as we saw majority so majority on two k
plus one bits is K stifled
the indexing function on K plus 2 to the
K bits is K stifled
and the inner product function is one
stifle it is not too stifled no matter
how large it is and this is a bit
surprising because we expect F composed
with inner product to be sorry in this
case parity DC entry size of s composed
with inner product to be at least the
decision tree size of s to the power n
where the inner product is on N plus n
Bits
um but we're not able to prove that with
this method of stifling
so that's an interesting open question
what other properties of pdts can we use
how can we prove a lifting theorem
in order to show that the PDT size
scales as the size of the inner product
Gadget increases
hopefully this will be insightful in and
give us more tools to work against
penities
the obvious open question is how can we
make the simulation theorem also work
for tax uh simulation theorem is
just the same as lifting theorem in this
slide
and yeah these are the main two open
questions
thank you for watching